what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the children of the Vault
and this story is so amazing but what
this does here is this picks up with
cable technically the children of the
Vault do appear a little bit earlier
than this but we'll kind of wrap back
around to them and make everything make
sense once we pick up with their
characters the
the cable is he's actually been held
prisoner for a month and that's one of
the reasons why for a lot of you all who
are following the X-Men comics and you
were wondering what ever happened to
Cable this is where he's been but the
whole reason why he's being held captive
specifically by orcas right the giant
anti-mutant organization that's out
there is because remember cable is a
time traveler he comes from the future
so them having access to everything he
knows about the past the present the
future it's the Rosetta Stone right it
would allow them to know what's going to
happen and to basically avoid those
pitfalls and ensure they come out on top
the other thing they've done here is
they've stolen his mechanical arm which
in all honesty is just kind of a crappy
thing to do but it is advanced
technology so it would make sense they
would take it in their possession the
other part of this is that even though
cable is an Omega Level telepath meaning
he's one of the most powerful telepaths
in existence that he stays confined
within what's basically a thought bubble
in the sense that orcas has constructed
a kind of thought about prison where he
can't control the minds of other people
now in reality he is
it'll telepath and telekinetic he is
exceedingly powerful but the funny thing
here is we're kind of given this bit of
a narration where we're told that like
cable would escape on his own within
three days instead he's rescued by none
other than Bishop now for those of you
guys who don't know the significance
behind this right like let's kind of
step away from this comic book for a
second I promise what I'm about to tell
you is amazing it's you're gonna
absolutely love this right so something
to understand is that cable and Bishop
both come from the future but they come
from two separate universes cable comes
from a future where the villain
apocalypse had taken over the world and
ruled with an iron fist Bishop comes
from a future where an event transpired
known as the six minute War so here's
how these two are linked right in Marvel
Comics in the aftermath of House of M
during the decimation era and a story
that's specifically titled Messiah
complex hopes Summers was born and she
was the first mutant born after the
Scarlet Witch took away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers it was huge deal
there was a Mad Dash to find this girl
the X-Men were trying to find her Mr
Sinister and his Marauders were trying
to find them and then William Striker
and his purifiers were trying to find
him when they all got to the village
that hoped signal was detected at in
Alaska basically the village had been
burned to the ground and everybody was
dead and so nobody knew where Hope
Summers went to come to find out cable
had snatched her up and then started
skipping through the timeline and the
reason why was because Bishop was
chasing them that in Bishop's Future
Hope Summers grows up to just become
this like crazy powerful but more or
less villainous girl who wiped out a
million humans in six minutes and that
basically jump starts like the Sentinel
program and more or less leads to Days
of Future Past the difference is that in
what was called The Summer's Rebellion
humans and mutants banded together and
then overthrew the Sentinels but Bishop
was always trying to find a way to keep
his future from coming into existence
once he realized it was hope cable fled
with hope Bishop chased after them and
the the two of them had just been
enemies for years and years and years so
the fact that like Bishop rescues cable
is a big deal here right so jumping back
to the story itself I told you it was
cool the X-Men in the mid-2000s were
amazing we need to go back and just kind
of cover that maybe we'll like dedicate
a day so we don't confuse everybody with
fall of X but the thing about this is
that cable and Bishop have a very
tenuous Alliance here and in fact one of
the things that happens is that as soon
as cable is basically released from his
captivity he uses his telepathy and
takes over the minds of the soldiers who
are shooting at them and basically
convince them or at least trick them
into believing that they're actually
spies for krakowa and so they're kind of
like their own personal Army now for
Bishop himself his ability is that he
can kind of absorb any form of energy
and then Channel it back in the form of
a concussive blast there are limits for
example if like Galactus were to attack
Bishop he wouldn't be able to absorb
that much power but somebody like
Cyclops or gunfire or something along
those lines absolutely and so of course
he's able to offer some measure of a
defense as well but using their own
telepathically manipulated private army
they effectively flee and then they
ultimately escape and so one of the
things that happens here is that cable
does not know about the events that went
into the fall of X which is to say orcas
launching a strike against the mutant
population Nimrod having seemingly
killed Juggernaut and then believed to
have killed Iceman that all these
mutants were sent away from Earth by
Xavier kind of forced to do that that he
doesn't know about any of that stuff and
so reading the mind of Bishop he gets
caught up super fast and the two of them
basically take off now we'll find out
where they went to but what we do here
is we actually switch over to the
children of the Vault themselves now the
great thing about this is that within
the comic the nature of the children is
explained incredibly well and so what
they do is they address the whole of
humanity and they say humankind do not
be afraid I am Seraphina of the voice of
the city and we are the children of
tomorrow they had kind of changed their
name they used to be called Children of
the Vault but she basically says we
speak to you now where you are in your
own language our words are gifts are for
everyone when our ancestors left you
they understood that humankind was on a
road to self-destruction that you would
need answers faster than you could hope
to find them they lock themselves away
in a place where time moves faster
though only a few decades passed for you
our society has progressed a thousand
thousand years right and so she says War
ecological catastrophe disease Prejudice
poverty and pain for us this is the
stuff of ancient history we solved your
problems Generations ago we wish to
share our Solutions with you all of you
freely we have already begun now here's
the thing to understand here despite the
fact that Seraphina presents herself and
the other children of the vault as
saviors in reality they're anything but
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with how all the X-Men were
being handled by Jonathan Hickman during
house and powers of x one of the things
he established is that at some point in
the future the children of the Vault
will go to war with humanity and the
mutant population and they will win they
will annihilate all of them and in fact
the children of the Vault and Humanity
will merge and become what were called
post-humans and then they would
eventually go off and do their own thing
and merge with the Phalanx and so on and
so forth but the thing about this is
they are basically nefarious and it's a
smart thing to do what better way to
conquer a land than to appear as a
savior earn the trust of the people and
then slowly subvert them from the inside
out and in fact that's exactly what they
do right we're literally told in the
poorest places on Earth self-replicating
Technology 10 000 years ahead of its
time unfolds and ingratiates itself
buildings composed of brand new elements
spring up overnight consuming and
converting the already existing
architecture as raw material bizarre new
skylines threatened virgins guys people
begin to call them Pueblos de Manana or
tomorrow towns right basically they're
giving people technology and resources
that can actually improve their lives
they give people resources and
technology that heals them restores the
ability to walk to those who lost it
right they step in and they end like
natural disasters that are threatening
to wipe out entire towns they very much
appear as saviors and that's the power
of the children of tomorrow because the
other half of this equation that
Seraphina didn't necessarily mention is
that with each new generation of the
children of tomorrow they become more
advanced than the previous generation
their powers multiply several times over
again so I would go so far as to argue
that while they're not specifically
listed as being like Omega Level Threats
they all basically are right I mean sure
they don't necessarily have like crazy
Advanced reality warping Powers but they
are incredibly capable now the funny
thing about this is that you initially
have orca this watching all of this
unfold and while orcas was the
organization that launched the strike
against the mutant population and really
kicked off the events of fall of X in
the first place they do nothing when it
comes to the children of tomorrow one
part of it is just due to the level of
power they have if they were to
challenge the children of tomorrow right
now they would get destroyed right they
would just I mean just like that it
wouldn't even be a challenge at all the
other reason though is because if
Society is looking over there there's
nobody looking over here and if there's
nobody looking here nobody's paying
attention to what you're doing right so
why look a gift horse in the mouth let
things just play out keep an eye on it
but it's all basically working to the
favor of orcas because with the children
of tomorrow the children of the vaults
whatever you want to call them getting
the attention of society nobody's focus
on Orcas that also means like the
Avengers and any other superhero teams
who are out there are watching them
they're not watching orcas slowly taking
over the world and so what you end up
doing here is you basically pick up with
cable and Bishop as they arrive in
Hell's Kitchen New York and one of the
things that cable reveals is that he's
just kind of going through and he's
looking at people's minds right reading
their minds to a degree and in fact he
even reads the mind of one guy who
refers to him as Josh Brolin right
obviously a play on the fact that Josh
Brolin played Cable in Deadpool 2. but
what he ends up revealing here is that
he also has a safe house right and of
course he always has safe houses cable
has safe houses everywhere right they're
all composed of ridiculously Advanced
Technology based out of his spaceship
gray Malkin but like really his time
travel ship but he has all kinds of
these things and what he starts to do is
actually rebuild his arm but basically
you get like all these crazy levels of
like arms and Armament like spaceships
and so on and so forth for Bishop one of
the things we learn is that the way in
which he survived undetected was by
resorting back to his own childhood
right kind of revisiting that bit of an
origin story to a degree during the time
before the Summer's Rebellion when
Bishop was living in that future he has
the M on his face because that's the
brand that you got if you were a mutant
but operating underground staying hidden
from Sentinels it was a very dark future
to live in but it's not that dissimilar
to the one that he's living right now
even if only in relation to the fact
that mutants are constantly being hunted
by orcas I mean it's not as dark in
terms of the environment right he's not
living in some post-apocalyptic
Wasteland where like all the superheroes
that ever existed are dead and mutants
are like fleeing for their lives and
that kind of thing it's not really that
dark right I mean it could get there but
it's not there yet and so once cable has
his arm back what he does is he actually
tells Bishop he'd been reading his mind
and something's off about his brain
right something's not quite right about
his head and what he tells him after
scanning his brain is that there's a
spot on his mind but the reason he
missed this is that it doesn't use
telepathy which would be something the
cable would immediately be able to pick
on if if Bishop was being controlled by
some telepathic Force out there cable
would have figured it out in instant and
he would have overwhelmed that
telepathic Force assuming it wasn't
somebody on par with like Xavier or Emma
Frost or something along those lines
right somebody comparable to him in
power but he even says I don't know what
it is that's going on there but it's
growing and when cable asked the
question like what do you mean by a spot
cable breaks out his own little computer
system in the form of a kind of AI nurse
and then sort of asked the question like
diagnose this and tell me what you think
it is and what he realizes once he scans
the analysis by the AI nurse is that
this kind of virus or whatever you want
to call it in the brain of Bishop is
composed of a bunch of different
organisms right there's the all God
organism from the dark rain the list
right the Wolverine One-Shot comic
you've got hawksbox which is basically
just some futuristic virus right hexis
the living Corporation the
techno-organic virus itself which
converts living tissue into Machinery
What's Happening Here is that this spot
is basically a kind of egg if we want to
call it that a virus is cable refers to
it what is designed to do is eliminate
individuality and instill absolute faith
in effect what it does is it takes
people and it puts them in the mindset
where they see the children of tomorrow
as their absolute saviors and any sense
of individuality begins to erode they
see them as an absolute now the fact
that it also involves a techno-organic
virus feeds into the post-human
philosophy in the sense that once a
group basically is infected by the
techno-organic virus to an extent that
there's no coming back they'll basically
create what's called a babble Spire that
will summon the Phalanx Covenant to
their planet and the phalan's Covenant
will start to incorporate and assimilate
all forms of organic and inorganic life
and then move on to the next World in
essence the children of tomorrow are
setting Humanity up to basically fall in
line with a group think philosophy and
then effectively become post-humans
they're fast tracking the Conquering of
the world and it is an incredibly smart
way to make because the world is already
so fractured within the Marvel Universe
anyway right it would make perfect sense
to make a move now if ever there were a
ton because if the Phalanx does show up
to Earth no one's going to be able to
stop them no one can defeat them any
Mutant that could defeat them is either
dead or missing and in fact in the
immortal X-Men Comics we find out where
they're at but it's just one of these
things where the end of the world
seemingly is not a bunch of catastrophes
happening at the same time and in fact
that's what cable says as he's talking
to Bishop he says this virus spreads the
way ideas spread right one person
becomes a Believer another person
becomes a Believer right basically it's
kind of spread throughout Humanity as a
whole we don't know exactly how it's
spread right we don't know like the
method of transmission we simply just
know it goes from one person to the next
but every time people pick up newspapers
they're looking at these headlines like
Humanity's existence has been extended
to 150 years tomorrow it might be 300
years right it might double and then it
might triple and so on and so forth to
where people basically defy death and so
it's one of those things where he says
we're talking high level semiotic
engineering the technology something
like this would take the children are
the best bet of doing it they're most
likely the ones that are doing all of
this and so when Bishop asked the
question how far reaching is this virus
cable looks out to everybody and
realizes every human being he can see
and presumably every human being on
Earth is infected there's probably
precious few who are not with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you need to get caught up on
fall of X make sure you click this link
to our playlist and I will catch you all
later
peace